in the last video we were talking about
the era of reconstruction and how after
the Civil War when the 13th amendment to
the Constitution outlawed slavery many
southern states enacted laws known as
Black Codes which in many cases were
really just slavery by another name they
prevented african-americans from voting
from owning firearms from not being in
some kind of labor contract or they
might be enslaved or jailed for vagrancy
and the North controlled by a Republican
Congress was outraged by these codes
having just fought an incredibly
destructive war to end slavery in
response to the Black Codes
Congress passed the 14th amendment to
the Constitution and the 14th amendment
guaranteed that anyone born in the
United States regardless of previous
condition of servitude had full
citizenship meaning they're entitled to
all the rights and privileges of being a
citizen and equal protection under the
law so a law could not target someone on
the basis of their race now to enforce
the 14th amendment Congress sent federal
troops to the states in the South
divided the southern region up into
military zones and said that the south
would be occupied by federal troops
until the states rewrote their
constitutions to recognize the 14th
amendment in effect to give equal
citizenship to African Americans fact
they also passed the Fifteenth Amendment
two years later in 1870 which said
voting rights are included among these
citizenship rights guaranteed in the
14th amendment I should mention that
these voting rights were only for
African American men as women will not
get the right to vote until 1920
so from the fourteenth ammendment until
1877 there is a military occupation in
the south and military troops are only
taken away from the southern states when
they rewrite their constitutions to
grant equal citizenship to
african-americans now you can imagine in
the South where whites have had racial
supremacy from the sixteen hundreds
getting them to recognize social
equality with african-americans was an
incredible struggle and it was a
struggle that the Republicans in
Congress and the federal troops really
didn't win this is the era of the Ku
Klux Klan which ran terrorist raids at
night trying to prevent
african-americans from voting or to
prevent their allies from helping them
to vote this era of reconstruction was
really a continuation of the civil war
where troops from the north tried to
enforce the 14th amendment tried to
enforce the end of slavery and the
citizenship of African Americans with
really implacable resistance from white
Southerners so by 1877 only two states
were left that still had troops because
the rest of the states had rewritten
their constitutions to acknowledge the
14th amendment but that is not to say
that racial equality had been achieved
in the South whatsoever so what happened
in 1877 which is generally known as the
end of Reconstruction and the beginning
of this period of Jim Crow segregation
well we'll get to that in the next video